hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the incredible battle
between osta and his own devil
in black clover this fight is going to
determine the future of
this series will asta's body be
possessed by the devil
as osta becomes a prisoner inside his
own body
or will asta tame his devil and force
him to work with him
as a team we also just got some crucial
new information about the devil's true
backstory so let's
get into it before we continue thank you
to honey for sponsoring this video we
all shop online
and with the current global health
crisis i've been doing more online
shopping than ever
whenever i go to check out with an item
i always see that little field for
coupon codes
and i'm thinking man i wish i had a
coupon but
now thanks to honey manually searching
for coupon codes is a thing of the past
honey is the free browser extension that
scours the internet to find coupons and
then automatically applies the best one
it can find
to your cart honey supports over 30
000 stores online everything from gaming
stores to fashion brands and even food
delivery
imagine you're doing some online
shopping with walmart when you check out
this little box drops down and all you
have to do is click
apply coupons wait a few seconds as
honey searches for the best coupons and
boom
the prices drop and you're saving money
honey has found over 2 billion dollars
in savings for its 17 million members
so if you don't have honey you could be
missing out on free money there's no
reason not to get it it's totally free
and it only takes a few seconds to
install install honey today to save
money for yourself
and to support this channel at the same
time go to joinhoney.com
uproar or click that link in the
description to get honey for free
and start saving today this video will
of course contain black clover manga
spoilers we are talking about the latest
developments in the story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned so
in the previous installment of the story
we learned the anti-magic devil's true
intentions
and we learned what drives him he spent
his whole life
being tormented by the other devils and
then
lucifer the strongest devil killed
lychita
his adoptive mother and the only person
in the world
who was ever kind to him liba is so
committed to destroying the other devils
and lucifer in particular that he is no
longer thinking rationally
asta tried to calm him down and just
talk things
out with him but liebe refuses to listen
he knows that he can't defeat lucifer
without a physical body
so he is determined to take over asta's
body so that he can finally
get his revenge as a result asta is
forced
to face off against liebe and he is
forced to fight
against his own devil as leibeth
threatens to take over
osta's entire body asta can tell from
liebe's key
that he is driven by an enormous amount
of rage and hatred
but also by sorrow and sadness because
of this
austin knows that liba is determined to
fight
so asta accepts his challenge
this is not the time to talk asta will
fight against his own devil
and he will win liber mocks asta when he
hears this
there is no way that a one-armed kid who
has no magic can defeat a devil
in battle and liebe wastes no time
he instantly launches an attack at asta
but not so fast libra asta may be
magicless
but he is able to use his incredible
physical strength and speed
to maneuver around the attack he then
runs
right up to liebe and punches him in the
face
as liba actually falls back from the
force of asta's punch
asta vows that even with his magicless
one-armed body
he can win and as the chapter continues
asta really demonstrates his
unbelievable
physical prowess because asta grew up
without magic
all he could ever do was train his body
physically
and he spent his entire life training
through
hours upon hours of vigorous exercise he
built his strength
speed and stamina to levels that other
humans
never reach the vast majority of humans
in that world
spend their time learning to perfect
their magical abilities
but asta spent all of his time
perfecting his body
and all that physical training is really
paying off
in this fight liba's biggest advantage
in battle is his ability to erase
the magic of others since the vast
majority of people in this world rely
primarily on their magic when they
suddenly
lose their ability to use that magic in
the presence of anti-magic
they instantly find themselves at a
massive disadvantage
but since asta has no magic of his own
liba's anti-magic has no effect
on him since asta relies on his physical
strength in battle
not on magic and since anti-magic
doesn't diminish his physical strength
asta is able to hold his zone against
liebe
this is exactly what noct notices when
he watches the fight from the sidelines
and i imagine that noct expected that
this
would happen if noct didn't believe that
asta could hold his own against liba he
never would have gone through all the
trouble to make
this showdown happen clearly noct
believes that asta can
tame liba and harness his power in time
for the spade kingdom infiltration and
that
is exactly why noct has taken such a
keen interest
in training asta noct is a smart guy
and i'm sure that his master plan has
accounted for
all of these variables nevertheless liba
is not deterred by osta's resistance
he quickly summons all three swords the
demon dweller's sword the demon
destroyer sword
and a demon slayer sword liba is able to
use
all three swords at the same time
because he is able to make them float
above him unlike osta liebe doesn't have
to actually handle the swords with his
hands
in order to use them he can just send
them flying through the air and control
them even from a distance
with his anti-magic obviously things
don't look great for asta
at this moment as liba sends three
powerful swords flying
right at him but there is still one
sword left
there is one sword that asta can use
asta still has yami's katana and he is
able to keep it
in his possession with the help of
yami's sword
asta is able to dodge and parry multiple
attacks from liba
but liebe is confident that asta will
lose in the
end no matter how strong he is
physically osta doesn't have powerful
magic tricks
up his sleeve and there is no way that
he could ever defeat a devil
and that goes double for a devil who is
of a higher rank
and possesses overpowered magic and
insane amounts of mana
as liba attacks asta determined to take
him down
we see a quick flashback that gives us
yet more information about liebe's
tragic
backstory in the previous chapter we
learned what happened to him
up to the point when he was sealed
inside the grimoire
but now we learned what he went through
inside the grimoire itself
while he was sealed inside the grimoire
libra felt like he was floating
in the middle of nowhere it was like he
was in some
empty endless void he had nothing to do
there
nothing to see nothing to hear all he
did was
curse lucifer and the other devils and
he allowed his rage to grow
stronger and stronger until it basically
consumed him
lieb has spent years and years just
seething about the devils and about
getting revenge
for lichita's death and this is why
liebe is so angry and emotionally
unstable
right now his entire existence became
dedicated to getting revenge
on the devils and this desire has turned
into an obsession
by the way it was definitely implied
that lichita died
from the wounds that she suffered at the
hands of lucifer but i don't want to
jump to conclusions
i mean if she had survived it would have
made sense for her to actually try to
find the grimoire and reunite with liebe
but who knows after what happened with
tethya and not to mention julius
i am not taking anyone's death at face
value
now according to this particular
translation of the chapter
and there are multiple translations out
there it seems that it was within the
grimoire itself that
liba learned to manifest the power of
anti-magick
he gained this unique and powerful
ability while raging out
inside the grimoire but he still
couldn't leave the grimoire itself
he was stuck there alone and desperate
until one day
the grimoire finally chose osta as its
new
owner because asta was born without
magic he became the perfect vessel for
liebe's anti-magic
but liber believes that in order to get
his revenge on the devils
he must take over asta's body
libid doesn't think that asta himself
will ever stand a chance against lucifer
so he wants to take this physical vessel
which has no magic
for himself since asta as he is right
now
failed to defeat dante and lucifer liebe
probably feels that taking over
is his only option what asta said
earlier
is true liba is not a bad guy and he
doesn't want to hurt
asta however liebe is so angry and so
obsessed with revenge that he is
prepared to do anything in order to
achieve his goal of destroying the
devils
so even though he may not want to hurt
asta if stealing asta's body is what it
takes to finally get his revenge
then liebe is prepared to do that even
if it does go against his personal
morals liba continues to use all three
swords to launch
multiple attacks at asta but because
asta can read ki
he is able to predict the movements of
the swords and avoid the attacks
as the fight rages on it becomes clear
that
asta has become an exceptional swordsman
since he first gained possession of the
five-leaf grimoire
in fact asta has learned a lot from
every previous opponent that he has
faced
and he has also learned a lot from yami
his captain who is a master swordsman
and the owner of the sword that asta is
currently using
right now in this crucial moment
asta is not just relying on his
impressive strength
and speed he is also relying on his
swordsmanship technique
and he is channeling everything that he
has learned during his time as a black
bull
from both friends and foes including
yami
kyoto leaked fansel krueger and mars
when you combine his strength and speed
with his technique and his ability to
sense ki
you quickly realize that even without
magic or anti-magic
asta is an extremely impressive
swordsman and
warrior even though libya is surprised
by asta's resilience he refuses to
believe that he could ever lose
to osta he spent years and years
plotting his vengeance and there is no
way that some magical human
is going to stop him now but on the
final pages of the chapter
asta manages to gain the upper hand and
he seemingly overcomes liba
using yami's katana i'm going to say
this right now i don't think the fight
is over i don't think that liebe will be
defeated this easily
and i think the next chapter will
continue the fight but we'll have to
wait and see
at any rate that is how this
action-packed chapter ends
with liba showcasing his impressive
anti-magic powers
including his ability to manipulate all
three swords at the same time even
without touching them
and yet asta manages to hold his own by
combining his impressive physical
strength
speed stamina and technique personally i
loved
this chapter i loved seeing liba's
anti-magic
inaction when he himself is using it and
i also loved seeing asta
standing up to liebe and holding his own
against
all odds on top of that i really
appreciated that additional little
flashback of liba
inside the grimoire this gave us some
idea of how libis spent
all those years inside the grimoire and
it turns out that he was just
seething about what happened to lichita
this eventually made him obsessed with
hatred and revenge
and that is exactly what drives all of
his actions today
at least for now one big question that
this chapter left me with was how and
why
did liba's anti-magic manifest inside
the grimoire
was it just his own latent ability that
he unlocked after
entering the grimoire or did something
else happen
for example did anti-magic appear inside
the grimoire because lychita's
absorption magic played some role in it
maybe a part of lychita's magic
combined with lucifer's magic that part
of lucifer's magic that lichita had
absorbed right before sealing the
way and maybe this combination of
various magical traits
created what we know today as anti-magic
maybe i'm overthinking this but it would
be cool if fanty magic
itself was a power that was never
supposed to exist
and it only came into existence as a
freak accident when lychita's absorption
magic combined with
lucifer's devil magic that would
definitely explain
why anti-magic is so powerful and why it
is so effective against
other devils like zagred if it really
comes from the magic of the strongest
devil lucifer
then of course it will be effective
against other devils
it would also be pretty ironic if in the
end lucifer is brought down by a power
that he himself
accidentally created but that's all
speculation at this point so i don't
want to jump ahead too far
at the end of the day this was a great
chapter and i expect that the fight
between azte and liba
will continue eventually though i do
think that asta will impress
liber enough for liba to realize that
the two of them will be stronger
if they work together and i think that
in the end they will use teamwork to
defeat
dante after all liba can control
anti-magic much better than asta
but asta has the physical strength and
technique that liba
just doesn't since the magicless but
physically strong asta
is the perfect vessel for liba i am sure
that they will arrive at some sort of
mutual agreement
eventually let me know what you guys
think did you enjoy this chapter and how
do you think that the battle between
asta and libit will end also where do
you think that anti-magic
came from was it just liba's latent
ability
or was it created by the combination of
lychita and lucifer's
magic don't forget to leave your
thoughts down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more blacklover content right
here on the channel please leave a like
to let me know it really does help
and if you're new to anime uproar or
maybe you just haven't subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all it's annoying but if you don't do
that you're still gonna miss a ton of
our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at uproar
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you